why don't I feeling this is got brakes
I've been expecting you up though
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay I'm gonna come and give me a hand
[Music]
[Music]
if you guys haven't subscribed to our
channel do us a favor and do it now you
won't regret it
come on make up you can do this it's all
about your spinning Anna
[Music]
so in the stereotypes video I had a grip
like this so let's see if I can actually
play with it it's better than my normal
[Music]
[Music]
well you worked for a while Oh baby
birds
what started as a joke actually worked
quite well for the challenge we need to
break the ball a bit I can't believe it
takes this many shots for after to break
a ball
[Music]
we call a crime there we have it
Oh God that's getting bigger I'm being
ready crack
he's going over your halfway not it
might be a bit of a challenge order
[Music]
[Music]
good training for reflexes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and I'm not there shouldn't be any
normal bounces anymore okay the final
stage of a broken ball now that's not at
all anymore do you think he's gonna work
I don't think so me neither
[Music]
okay I think we're we're done with this
challenge leave your ideas for the next
challenge episode in the comments and
hit subscribe so you don't miss it until
next time